the worldview 3 satellite passing over
Southern Japan spies something in the
forest below
this report shows that Japanese
scientists were running an experiment to
see how a space affects tree growth
so what they did was plant 10 concentric
rings of trees they had this same amount
of trees in each ring so when you were
closer to the center of course they were
closer to each other
in a feat of superhuman scientific
endurance over the next half century
botanist painstakingly monitor how each
ring of trees develops
and as you get out from that Center they
get more spaced more room for sunlight
and more room for the roots to grow and
get water so of course they grew taller
while the scientific importance of this
strange experiment may be debatable
its impact from space is hard to deny